my dress-up darling might have possibly
graced us with the single best girl ever
created the cure for cancer the theory
of relativity hirohiko araki's secret to
aging all of these trivial things pale
in comparison to the biggest scientific
breakthrough the modern world has seen
as after years of trials and research
science may have well created the
perfect waifu this is the best girl of
best girls the anime girl he tells you
not to worry about the final boss of
life is mario kitagawa our best girl so
great so clearly above the rest i can't
wait for her to not be nominated at the
anime awards next year
after over 10 years since i laid eyes on
this scissor obsessed crabs infected
psychopath and two years since i saw
chizuru in the critically acclaimed fan
favorite harem romance anime
dojin rent a girlfriend
i didn't think any girl could come along
to rival them so quickly in my heart but
like gatama buddha in 500 bce i may have
just attained spiritual awakening as
basking in the mere presence of marin
kitagawa has opened my third eye to
possibly become my new favorite anime
girl of all time that is absolutely
unconditionally without a shadow of a
doubt not because she reminds me of my
fiance hey guys but because she reminds
me of my favorite v tuber hey guys so
without further ado here is my 1 000
scientific fully peer-reviewed thesis
shut the [ __ ] up on why maron kitagawa
is quite possibly the best girl of our
generation that may usher earth into an
era of prosperity that brings humanity
into his second renaissance and you know
why you should be watching dress up
darling because it's a bloody great show
[Music]
but before that i'd like to talk about
the sponsor of today's episode call of
auntie hey there you're looking a little
stressed right now and if you are maybe
call avantia is the perfect stress
relief that you need this is a brand new
match 3 rpg game with beautiful music
and animation setting a new benchmark
for casual games the thrilling match 3
gameplay combines epic puzzle battles
with magic and dragons and for god's
sakes who doesn't love dragons yes we
got dragons for days they're your secret
weapons in battles and your strongest
allies on your adventure to meet
legendary figures from across its world
there are over 60 heroes to collect that
you can level up and upgrade to using
your arsenal right now you have the
chance to summon a legendary four-star
hero for free morgan okay i admit i
don't give pirate girls enough love but
that's about to change because sign me
up captain it looks like there's a new
pirate queen in town if you get bored
there are also tons of different modes
from alliance wars 1v1 battle and fallen
titans and there are also tons of events
constantly that give you free items so
if you want to enter the world of auntie
today then you can click the link in the
description or more conveniently you can
just scan this nice little qr code to
download the game now and don't forget
you could also use promo code to gig up
for some freebies thank you to call of
duty for sponsoring today's episode and
with that said back to my dress-up
darling there's been a genre that's been
popping up recently that i like to call
best girl the anime series about a plain
typically average guy going into a story
all about how their life got flip turned
upside down by the appearance of a
single anime girl who feels like they
were perfectly engineered to be the
ultimate life form a waifu these shows
dangle the discord girl you wish you had
complete with a charming adorable
dynamic with the main lead baiting us
and us weebs bite hook line and sinker
giving us hope in the darkest of places
cause if you think there's no chance of
you finding a girl like this just
remember no matter what kind of person
you are no matter how lonely you feel
never forget that there are
approximately 4 billion girls alive in
the world right now
and you chose to fall in love with a
[ __ ] drawing i've never seen a woman
i think the first time i saw a show
radiate the same kind of energy without
the romance was with the outer worldly
horror lovecraftian nightmare creature
umaru-chan proving that in the pursuit
of greatness science may have
accidentally created cancer but all
these past attempts have now been
rendered mute as we have now found the
absolute pinnacle of the genre in my
dress-up darling wakana gojo has a
secret he spends his days perfecting the
art of making hina dolls a hobby he
adopted from his grandfather he keeps to
himself about it because as a kid one of
his childhood friends found out and was
like yo did you just post cringe no no
this isn't cringe bro this is great
an experience that taught him to keep
his hobbies to himself and close himself
off from the people around him
completely that is until one day a girl
comes literally flying into his life
did it hurt
when you fell down from heaven
look like her she's confident sociable
popular but of course she too has a
secret
she's a weeb
not only that but she has a big passion
in cosplaying anime characters game
characters eroger characters she wants
to cosplay them all except just one
problem she sucks at making costumes so
when she finds out about gojo's love for
making hino dolls despite his fear she
finds his craft incredible and enlists
his help to make the costumes of her
dreams and so begins this delightful
rom-com between the unlikely couple as
gojo goes from making traditional
japanese dolls to anime costumes galore
see if you're wondering why dress up
darling was one of the most popular new
anime of the season well the answer is
pretty obvious a charismatic hot girl
who's into anime games and even hentai
wants to cosplay and isn't afraid to be
lewd she's like my perfect anime
girlfriend my best girl senses were
tingling from just a single glance it's
almost like she was perfectly designed
to take over the anime community and
that's exactly what she did screenshots
fan art appreciation posts marin almost
immediately took over my timeline and
refused to leave and you know what when
i see the internet collectively creaming
their pants over the hottest new anime
girl of the month my knee-jerk reaction
is the unstoppable urge to take the piss
out that girl cause i'm what's normally
referred to as a [ __ ] [ __ ] so i
went to do my dress-up darling with all
defenses up an impenetrable waifu
fortress that could not be broken no
matter what and it went a little
something like this yeah i mean she's
alright but nothing so special so far
no
i can control this
like every top tier anime girl their
strength lies in the quality of their
blush and the first time i saw that beef
red face turn around i
so hard i thought my heart was about to
go into cardiac arrest but it was gonna
take more than a red face to win me over
and marin conquered my heart faster than
the mongols conquered asia maron just
radiates this charisma that commands
every moment she's on screen she's
charming yet relatable eccentric while
being a grounded person if she was born
in the roman times wars would have been
fought for her we may very well be
witnessing apotheosis in anime form here
is a goddess living in the realm of
girls gentlemen
we may have in fact found
the original sigma female that's right
there's none of this no baby it's not
because i like it
here is a sigma that fully embraces our
true feelings immediately accepts them
and pursues them where other anime girls
take ten thousand years waiting for the
ship to come she's full on michael
phelpsing herself towards the ship she's
lewd without being immodest in an era
which drove people to say silence wench
i don't want to be horny i just want to
be happy mari says who decided you can't
be horny and happy
please don't luna she's a precious
little cinnamon bun pathetic here's a
girl so headstrong so strong-willed
she's determined to loot herself before
any rule 34 artists could and that's
because marin rule 34 kilagawa gets it
she understands the struggle of man for
you see
you don't fap because it's easy
you fap because it's hardly any time
passes in this anime without the
animators fully showing their
appreciation of marin's assets all
around alright let me say this is a
horny show and it looks [ __ ] great if
hentai was are then this is the sistine
[ __ ] chapel of smart and poor old
gojo here is just standing there
casually displaying the willpower of a
[ __ ] green lantern candidate with the
damn mona lisa of waifu standing in
front of him this may make you think
that dress up darling is just another
fan service show with the newest hot
waifu of the month and well that is
absolutely true but also missing a
massive part of what makes this show so
great this may be a horny show but it's
an equally if not more wholesome show
amasaka for stories about people
pursuing or expressing their passions
and this show has that in spades for
anyone interested in cosplay the show
breaks down the process to the smallest
detail someone like me would have never
considered before a lot of research has
obviously been put into this and the
attention to detail shines through but
beyond this it does such an amazing job
in conveying the love behind the craft
and why people find such a delight from
doing it i've never tried cosplaying
gore had any drive to do so but seeing
the pure joy of these people being able
to become the characters they so love
and respect i can't help but catch some
of the joy being radiated from them and
it helps me understand cosplaying in a
way i never had before i think the exact
moment i fell in love with this show was
the first time a costume was completed
due to a miscommunication and a complete
lack of understanding with how long it
takes to complete a costume maren
unknowingly pressures gojo into making a
cosplay 4 character she really wants to
become in a ridiculously unreasonable
time scale he stresses himself beyond
belief and pushes himself to complete
burnout but somehow someway he finds a
way to push through and finishes it and
when marin sees the final product and
finds out everything he's been through
you see her acting like
a decent human being she doesn't wave it
off to have it divulge into a comedic
moment she fully realizes the [ __ ] up
she's done the amount of pressure she's
put him through and gives a genuinely
tear-filled apology most youtubers can
only dream of doing there is real regret
from a female lead but gojo being the
guy that he is accepts it and moves on
he can see how much he wants to become
this character how passionate about it
she is and if he can make her feel the
happiness of achieving that then it's
all been worth it so after all that they
decide to try it on and you can see that
it's freaking perfect glee and
excitement oozes through you can see the
exact moment her passion becomes
realized and it's one of the most
uplifting feelings i've felt from such a
simple moment and i think that's what
truly makes the romance work in this
series as much as marin steals the show
let's not pretend that gojo isn't the
[ __ ] catch he's timid and shy but
he's a genuinely earnest guy who pours
his whole soul into his passions he puts
everything into fully bringing marion's
hobbies into fruition he finds a sincere
happiness in bringing joy to the people
around him but it's also in service for
his own dreams of perfect his craft with
hina dolls he's an individual with his
own goals and aspirations and it's by
being around maher and that helps him
realize that he shouldn't be ashamed or
closed off about his own passions in
some anime romances you hope the main
couple get together because the plot
dictates that they would be happy
together so of course you got to cheer
for them but here you get the sense that
the two are genuinely made for each
other this isn't a one-way street they
bring out the best in each other while
helping to cover each other's worst
sides they both equally help each other
grow and to me that's the true sign of a
great couple because lads do you know
what's better than witnessing a smile
you want to protect
it's witnessing a smile that you helped
earn gojo isn't the typical self-insert
protagonist he may initially seem like
on the surface but i would be lying if i
didn't see a part of my old self in him
if anyone's seen my you'll grow out of
anime video you'll know i have an eerily
similar story to gojo from when i was a
kid involving a pokemon pencil case and
some girls who thought that no one my
age should still be into pokemon and
that experience stuck with me anime is
my passion and has been for a very long
time but for a large portion of my life
i was ashamed to own up to it when i was
growing up anime gaming and nerdy [ __ ]
in general was looked down upon and
laughed at so i kept it to myself i was
a closet anime fan for the longest time
even when i was in uni making the good
old anime zone reviews not a single
person around me knew that i'd even
liked anime let alone made youtube
videos about it it was only when i grew
older that i actually met people who
accepted my passions made friends who i
could nerd out with surrounded myself
with people who accepted the real me who
helped me feel confident in being open
and pursuing my passions and now you
can't [ __ ] shut me up about topics
i'm passionate in and that to me is what
makes marin best girl she isn't true
waifu material because she's a sexy
cosplay girl who's into anime and video
games and likes all the same nerdy [ __ ]
you like but because she's down to earth
chill compassionate and most importantly
she's so unashamed in being the person
she is someone who's completely upfront
with their own feelings and passions
someone who's not only honest to the
people around her but herself as well
someone who doesn't put you down for the
weird things you may like but encourages
you to accept it and embrace it because
she takes a genuine interest in the
people around her such a force of
positivity exudes an energy that is
irresistibly addictive it can give
comfort to the people that need it most
it can bring the most closed off person
out of their shell everyone deserves
zamar and kitagawa in their life and i'm
not talking about waifu material it
could be a girlfriend boyfriend best
friend family member distant relative
someone who's able to bring out the best
in you just by being around them and
that's why to me marin is without a
shadow of a doubt my best girl of 2022
jk it's just because she reminds me of
sydney
[Music]